hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Red Dead Redemption
- we just upgraded the camp just a
little bit foods not ready yet but we
got new guns new ammo I want to go see
what John Marston is all about over here
hey John hmm okay bye cold did you mean
cold because I think that might be who
you were talking about over there
alright so we just did err Strauss
quests over there so what we could
probably do after I stop by that what
yes what yes okay
what did that have to do with me I don't
even know who Mary is morning what
ok never mind that you didn't have
anything important to say god dammit
everyone's always bugging me with their
business also I realized whenever I play
these like long gaming sessions I just
get deep into a little shaving kit
well Movember is over I guess I could
shave a bit pomade hair trim pomade
facial hair
wait where's I don't have any pomade to
apply I could trim my own hair man's let
it grow wild
I can't shave it right now apparently so
what is this little question for anyway
good letter
ok sure whatever dear Arthur I've
written this letter a hundred times or
more and I cannot get it right it's me
you know it's me from the bad
handwriting I know I said when we last
spoke and I was going off to get married
that we would not speak again I know I
said a lot of things and I meant them I
suppose at the time but I'm not so proud
as to not speak to people who care for
me or cared for me I've been in
Valentine for a couple of months I had
some bad look and well it's a long story
and not an interesting one but I am here
for now I saw a couple of the girls or
whatever the polite term is for them
that ran with you and your associates in
town and I heard tale of a man who
sounded like you I would love to see you
again if you could spare me a little bit
of your time I'm renting a room at
Chadwick farm just north of Valentine I
mean marry Linton ok Mary I was just up
at Chadwick farm I beat the [ __ ] out of
a guy I accidentally kicked him to death
and then I restarted the universe and
then I didn't kick him to death I'm
gonna talk much about that but I need to
take a nap first just a little bit of a
nap we'll go till evening fine I can't
do all this day [ __ ] it's not for me
writer just don't feel right but okay I
mean I got nothing else to do so I guess
I'll go see marry whoever marry is I'm
guessing it's an ex just judging by the
the tone of the letter an ex wants to
reconnect at some point but I'm a bad
man and I told Letty the know whatever I
gotta go find out what the guns are all
about here if I could find a better one
I don't think I can take I guess this
isn't really a shop okay I gotta say
they really nailed like all the
animations here I feel like they must
have built a really good engine for it
because vinyl rockstar liked the way
they built the animations in the
previous one was that the animations
were all I don't know not procedurally
generated that's not the right term for
it but like artificially intelligently
generated in a certain way I know it's
hard to say but it's just fascinating
okay let me see on the map where exactly
we're going because I might actually be
wrong about that where I remember before
okay Mary oh no that is a different
place okay maybe I didn't Oh
emerald ranches where I went but I'm
wanted over there so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna go over here I'll probably pay my
bounty on the way back and I'll just
never go over to strawberry ever again
I'm gonna run out of money before I'm
careful
I know well whatever maybe I'll last sue
me up another deer at some pointer here
it's not it's not the most uh not the
most cautious way to catch a deer but it
is the most cost-effective get real
intimate with the deer before its
untimely demise but only if I run across
one how about no oh [ __ ] sorry sorry
[Music]
oh come on I was right there god damn it
why I guess he was right there to
point-blank but whatever man I was just
trying to be fancy about it goddamn it
okay whatever I get it whatever it ain't
no thing I killed four of them they only
killed one of me it was fair exchange no
matter what now let's go hopefully
seeing the ex isn't gonna be any worse
than what I just encountered so whatever
hey I'm here to pay my bounty pal
look look look friend there you go
yeah and he's done don't worry about it
hey how's it going I'm here to pay my
bounty keep getting into trouble for
some reason I don't know why whatever is
stupid
it sure does especially when you murder
a whole bunch of people
anyway she around the band letter from
Bubba look what heard to Bubba from
Julian did I just beat up Bubba said who
I just beat up yeah whatever
all right hop buddy dude let's go see
the ex married would trouble
howdy howdy howdy howdy
oh not what I meant not what I meant
either excuse me
the thing about this game is like you're
not really supposed to take it at a full
sprint the entire time I have a funny
feeling that you're supposed to like you
know kind of patiently wait your way
through things full sprint straight
through town hopefully I don't kill
anybody alright Mary let's see what this
sordid business is gonna all be about
hello knocking knock we loved once and
true heart to disturb you ma'am just the
traditional way of answering the door in
the West I mean you gotta
you just gotta hello oh hello Mary
[Music]
I heard you and your friends was around
I okay where's what's-his-name died I'm
sorry to hear that
yeah me too happened a while ago
pneumonia
bad business sure so you've been laid a
widow and come here looking for me is
that it no ain't like that author oh
okay I my family I need your help
you ain't the family that always looked
down on me you want me to help it's my
little brother Jamie I always liked
Jamie at least compared to the rest he's
broken daddy's heart daddy has a heart
don't make me beg you Arthur my money
mom me I wasn't good enough I'm sorry we
need your help
real bad well Jamie's joined the cello
nians that strange religious order good
for him
they're quite mad Arthur they'll kill
him you're the only person he'd listen
to so I'm too rough to marry into your
family but it's okay to ask me to help
and saving your family I'm sorry I
understand if you don't want to help me
but but I think of you often long time
ago now I'm begging you Arthur
I say let Jamie live Jamie's life and
not the nightmare that his daddy dreamed
up for Jamie's so innocent Arthur
please Arthur will you help me alright
god damn it okay somewhere out near
Carmody Dell I think the rancher there
seen him around the Cumberland forest
area I just want him back Arthur if you
find him bring him to me at the station
I'll see what I can do I'll owe you you
already owe me no cold-blooded yeah got
him got her yeah I feel good about that
one
okay I mean I've got no stick in the
game out one way or another but there's
obviously some woohoo there's all
there's like ten train loads of baggage
just dripping out of there okay so what
do we got here what are we doing here we
go
all the way up there what's that all
about all right I'll go find your
goddamn brother and I'll bring him back
whatever but for someone I stopped by
the store because I'm gonna sell some
stiff I think I got stuff to sell uh uh
uh they may not be open and the only
reason I believe that that would
actually be a thing years because this
game is pretty faithful and all the
stuff that's been recreating so anyway
I'm gonna skadoodle over here I'll be
back once I get over there
yeah
what the hell my horse up and died on me
twisted my ankle something fierce think
you could give me a ride yeah I can oh
thank you sir thank you you know emerald
ranch mine taking me there it's not too
far out of my way I think yeah do that
I'm such a kind hearted man all right
lady fine let's go over that way I did
not ask lady to lift a drink of course
marriage for me has been nothing but
trouble lady Oh biscuit he was a fine
animal brain didn't take no guff not
from no one well yard had one of them
Mountain Boys pull a gun on me once I
was riding up near the Dakota and it
stopped by a nice warm patch must have
dozed off but I wake up and find some
nasty piece of work pointing a rusty
shotgun straight at me well he gets
reason on and I must have made some sort
of noise because the next thing I know
this get had nipped easier clean off
kicked his hide to as he was hollering
away didn't think a man could run so
fast oh yeah yeah had a good laugh on
that one I tell the husband what does he
do
should've never gone over there honey
says gee thanks the time being I was
looking for work they was looking for
some help with the gardens if I waited
any longer from my husband put food on
the table I'd have died of starvation
I'll be moving on soon though
emerald ranch well it's a strange place
oh sure the owners a mean bastard
strange to the
I said boolean folk there's a daughter
but she never leaves the house you can
see her in the window sometimes when I
asked about her everybody told me to
leave it alone found an old saloon there
oh here's bullet holes Oh blood stains
something definitely happened there but
I couldn't figure it just an
uncomfortable feeling to the place
either way it's time I left especially
now I lost that poor horse I'll collect
my belongings and be on my way home I
guess my husband's right where I left
him bottle in hand okay lady I'm sure
I'm glad that you told me your whole
life story on this endeavor yeah we sure
are is and then you can be on your way
and then I can be on my way and then we
can forget this whole conversation ever
happened all right here you go
what is it well you just give me oh well
see ya later you know I gotta admit
without this mode this cinematic mode
right here black and just hold on it
sticks to the trail it just goes this
game would not be nearly as fun but as
it stands like I think the developers
knew that the environment would be so
pretty the people would actually like
kind of going through everything it
gives things a sense of importance when
it takes effort to do it's kind of like
to go back to world warcraft again but
you remember when they added in like
automatic dungeon group finders who's
incredibly convenient feature it's
something that everybody started using
was like is great is wonderful but also
it just really stopped people from going
out in the world
now people only live in the cities cuz
they don't need to go I mean for the
initial questing you got to go out but
like it used to be a top level you would
have to get a group together in the city
then venture out together you would all
move over there the lazy people would be
like shaman may shaman me but you'd
still all move out there I would always
be one of the first people to get there
because I wanted to like good things
going even if we had to summon people
you know something great about something
great about experiencing the world of
the place things can be spoiled with
fast travel and I think this one is just
a really good way to like make sure that
you actually understand the world
delivered even if there is a forum fast
travel with like the trains the fact
that it costs money the fact that is so
restrictive the fact that it's limited
and where it can drop you off I think
that's great
I think it is like a lot of people might
over time be like oh so T's I've seen
the world already but at the same time
what they've done is they populated the
world so much and it's not just like Far
Cry 5 or is like every few feet you run
into someone that needs rescue or an
ambush or whatever have you like this
one feels alive you know and the
weirdest way possible it feels really
alive they've done a great job with this
and an honest appreciate it for good
games you know I don't often play
triple-a titles but when a good one
comes along that really really shows us
stuff
that's awesome are we getting close now
where are we
yeah we're getting kind of close alright
let's see what the sorted business with
my axes brother is come on now wait
isn't this where I shot that bear I
never did get my Pelt back let me see if
I can get this gotcha gotcha come on
come on now come on now Bessie
if that charged me right now I would be
so very dead oh I'd be so dead excuse me
oh I'm sorry
oh sorry about that no I guess I can't
pick it up I guess it is pretty huge
yeah it is that is indeed pretty huge I
also like the changes that they made on
this because in the last game it was
just like a shoot skin shoot skin didn't
Matt bear coyote anything to shoot skin
meat stuffing bags this one like I like
the limitations of it yep just a fat in
the old pocket okay no I really do I've
really liked the limitations I think a
lot of things in games today are given
too easily to people you know you don't
need it to be easy all the time it does
not have to be you're gonna have things
be a challenge and it could be good it
could be rewarding and I think they've
really done that here and I think it's
it's hard hard for a game developed her
to recognize that sometimes to recognize
that convenience isn't everything
because sometimes you do need
convenience sometimes you do sometimes
you have to make your game accessible
I'm not gonna bother with it because I
just don't want to be interrupted
because I want to get over to where I'm
going okay so we're right here yeah so
it's a it's a fine balance and you know
there's this a real solid rule to say
which is what what is
because I could have just easily made it
the same way as before and I never would
have known any different I'd have been
like oh hell yeah this is my favorite
part of the first game but now it's like
different you got a you gonna work for
him that's cool eventually if I ever go
on super hunting trips I bet I if I take
a wagon I would be able to get a lot
more stuff I'd be able to haul more
things hunt more at a time get more
money from it but still it's a challenge
all right hell up whoa
okay holy [ __ ] okay all right show us
safety it is then hello go speak to the
boy hello Sean your sisters very worried
the boy is chosen a path sir
true
well his sister just wants to speak with
Arthur I've chosen a path
the boy has chosen a path he's chosen
safety what path have you chosen sir
um still searching I guess we are all
searching chelonian ism is about
searching what do we search for do you
think oh oh oh purpose safety safety and
meaning Jamie knows the truth but of
course you may speak with him
exactly if your teachings are so great
what harm can undo I'm
I'm not
I'm not coming with you Arthur just come
and speak with me hey wait a minute why
I got a last sue you kid hey I killed
the last guy I last sued accidentally
what am I gonna do if I intentionally do
to you huh alright here we go again my
pal my goddamn Pelt god damn it where to
go off that's not really that funny but
my god that was love physics in games
looks just like complete nothin's gonna
get my last scene one of the hell's is
this disappeared [ __ ] alright this
guy here's me
I don't know a part of a cult - maybe if
you'd listen to me for a little bit mmm
uh okay whatever you say you know I envy
you as my damn business either be your
sister my ex suddenly contact me to look
your sister god damn it okay all right
come on you might be right about that
you might be a hundred percent right but
takes crazy - no crazy
heck I could have been your uncle or
your half-brother I don't know what I am
I don't I don't know what I would have
been you
[Music]
hey whoa hey that's your right hey are
you shooting straight up that's not
really very threatening hey what are you
doing to those poor cows come on man
Oh Oh sprint sprint careful leave me
alone they're good people
I'm warning you Arthur Morgan
uh-oh you goofed it now please put that
gun down no no okay wait wait wait wait
wait wait no what no that's a little
extreme reaction to what's the situation
here
that's pretty I was gone I'm not good
with controller yeah okay god there's a
lot of extreme motions none of that none
of that have none of that we'll have
none of that
let's go see your sister okay try
yourself you stupid kid one thing I do
know there ain't no shame in looking for
a better world
I missed you sir are you and Mary sweet
on one another again should I get this
horse
didn't try to kill yourself you know you
taught me how to ride a horse
well apparently Bonilla nope really
you'd fall for that they were very nice
to me
they're decent
please tell me you didn't give him any
money of course I did they rely on
charitable donations triple I just
wanted to believe that there might be
something good coming my way one day
guess that's dead in the water
with the turtle yeah Oh father kept
telling me was you won't amount to
anything you're not enough of a man I
had to get away I couldn't take it
anymore
but your father's a bully and a coward
don't listen hey don't talk about him
like that
what do you want me to say Jaime he's a
good father nice man he won't be happy I
saw you please send him my worst regards
thing is he's right I'm not good at
anything come on tell me something you
like don't think too hard
apples I guess ok carpentry horses
[Music]
that's oaken you must really like
shooting and robbing people only like
shooting young idiots you run away from
me when I'm trying to help father told
me what you do I'm sure are you still
with Dutch and what was his name Esther
Jose yep still the same sort of and
Annabelle and Bessie I'm afraid they're
dead [ __ ] maybe Mary did make the right
choice anything like the nonsense you
reading the newspapers so are you two
getting back together I told you no just
asked me for a safe you know Barry
Linton's dead pneumonia you told me so
the door is open so to speak Matchmaker
over here he's not and you seem just the
same let's just get you back waiting at
the station for us okay and we're gonna
forget about the alternate reality where
I didn't manage to shoot the gun out
because I didn't know that I had to
press the button again cuz that's what
happened Knowsley come over there I
thought it was gonna like you to do the
red X thing I thought it was gonna like
automatically do it but yeah shut up kid
I'm nervous what are you looking at
howdy doodly Doo Dah whatever no yeah
[Music]
home please you've fathers been very sad
father wouldn't know sadness if it died
in his bed but I'll come home for you my
boy my sweet boy come on
Oh Arthur thank you thank you it's good
to see you Mary and you Arthur and you
I'm your oh you'll never change I know
that the most tragic thing that you can
see about stories like this is like you
see little glimpses of what could have
been I think that's like just analogous
to life right you see little paths that
you can take you know depending on what
[Music]
I trust I will not make a god-awful fool
of myself once more but yeah that's the
thing like you see what could be in
these people's lives I like it the same
in the same way and for yourself like
life is full of choices what you're
gonna do
who knows what you're gonna do sometimes
in the end like you don't know what the
what the road will lead to you like will
you be happy because will you be will he
be happy if he gave up his life that he
lives right now the only life that he
knows whoops let me sneak around here a
little bit the only left that he really
knows just so he can get like back with
Mary and something like that I mean in
that short exchange even I was like oh
just get back with her come on man she
clearly loves you she would take you
back in a heartbeat looks like it's not
true to his like who he is
so sad to see all right fine brandy this
not my beans not my beans let's get the
gin let's get the awful here see cigar
that can go what do we got here I can
sell the bourbon I think the stuff all
right anything else nothing that you'd
want I need to go to the
which where do I sell like my special
super supplies like the like the Rings
and the antique pocket watches cuz I got
a bunch of those and I can sell to this
person I don't know know how much I
actually have because I just like I've
lost so much of it over the you know but
I got nothing just an antler right you
want some of it see there's like
treasures here but I don't know where to
sell them yeah whatever
I'll hold on to it I've got 90 bucks
it's good enough for now what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna go in here cuz the beard
is annoying me I'm gonna get rid of the
beard he's gonna look so weird without a
beard but I know there's a barber in
here you don't get in barber or hey man
come on give you a haircut are you
talking what's wrong with your face
all right what do we got full styles
clean shape oh that's what his face
looks like the English Maltese flying
fork current length is too short
oh okay so if I grow it a little longer
I can get that ha ha I'm gonna wait for
that yeah I'm gonna wait for that that
is it's too good to pass up I can't pass
up that is just too good I'll come back
later I'll come back later
dude it's 1899
this is more shops look at all this
industry here that's not the same baby
all different now newfangled gas-powered
horses everywhere let's see what we got
going on there's some kind of question
mark that's been here for a while but
I'm my ignore it for the time being uh
who we got over here
who is this Hosea Javier
oh that's right we needed to rescue Sean
oh okay I'm gonna go down to I'm gonna
go down to Xavier because I've been
putting that off for a while so I'm
gonna go see what the deal is with that
then I'll come back later yeah whatever
man you don't you don't own me you don't
know me you don't own me and then
someday I'm actually gonna I'm actually
gonna bring back a goddamn animal but
that day is not today
oh also I need to brush my horsey hey
horsey hello hey autumn Oh brush you
brush you you won't breathe you've all
brisket brushy do you get brushy you get
brushy you want brush yeah that's a good
boy
thank you good boy oh yeah he's a good
I don't know how much I need to brush
you there's no I haven't brushed you
since I got you how about feed you want
some food ah
Oh nom nom nom Oh nom nom nom nom
alright how about good Pat a good pair
we'll go all right let's do this back in
the saddle again
now which way am I going I have no idea
but I'm gonna try to not break any laws
on the way there we've got a long road
out of us so I will see you when we get
there
Rin cinematic look at that just look at
that goddamn beautiful cat den beyond
beautiful I hope I'm going the right way
because if I can if I'm just running
into the woods with no sense of
direction then I don't know what I'm
gonna be doing with that
oh hello howdy yeah man I don't know I
mean the thing is like I thought I would
have had a general idea of what the
story arc is gonna be I mean obviously
the story arc is kind of already defined
because you know how it gets from A to B
the first game to the second or the
second game to the first game
considering this is a prequel but you
know how that's generally gonna be right
you have a great understanding of it so
there's gonna be the story of this gang
and how this game came to be and the
challenge that it faces it's gonna be
defined by like the the the feud between
Dutch and Colm
but at the same time I feel like there's
a greatest story being told that's gonna
be told about like John Marston
eventually betraying his entire family
here because this is his family and that
is the story of the first Red Dead
Redemption is like Marston hunting down
and killing every single one of these
people in an attempt to live a life and
in the end it didn't work and that's the
saddest thing about it is like this is
that's the the hint of sadness that
surrounds every little piece of this
story it's like when you live a life
like this you can live a life like this
but it always ends one way and blood
then you live by the sword you die by
the sword that ol dad just like you live
by the gun and you die by the gun like
that's just how it is cuz like no matter
what what you say it like it is fun but
also there's as little pieces of the
culture of it where it's like it is kind
of [ __ ] up like I'd go beat this
polish guy up for money and I take all
of his prized possessions and then I
stop it like taking his wedding ring cuz
I'm like all right I get it that's a
little bit much but at the same time
it's like man it's not good it can seem
free and it can seem fun and you know
maybe there's a
of adventure and all the Sakana like
yearns for that feeling of of total
freedom just living on your own and
living by living by no laws but your own
but at the same time it's it's not good
it's not good at all but I mean it was
part of our history not a lot of us did
this but some people did same with
pirates back in the day and all stuff
like that it's fascinating it's just the
different lengths humans will go to live
out their lives
anyway I'm waxing philosophical here but
when all I've got is time to wander on
the empty roads what else am I gonna
talk about listen to the awesome
soundtrack well it's there and I'm sure
that if you do this day in and day out
for years and years it gets kind of
boring but it's just like sitting in
traffic you know I mean I equivalent but
you know to them I didn't know any
better grab it that's not a good or a
bad close one I mean it's just like yes
life on horse now I don't know why but I
really want a horse we got to be getting
close
why should I all right fine all right
[Music]
oh really I knew it I had a funny
feeling okay here we go here we go this
is what I was talking about all right
hey buddy
I had a funny feeling that didn't seem
too trustworthy but yep man who'd a
thunk yeah well that sucks for you well
when you rob the wrong person
live by the gun die by the gun yeah okay
thank you come on and now I want a horse
never wanted a horse in the entire me on
my life I've never even wanted a horse
in the first Red Dead Redemption game
but now I really want a horse demon I
mean it sounds like hell to take care of
a horse you have it a ranch lots of land
that's pretty good she could have room
to roam chicas never seen a horse before
chicas never seen a horse I have no idea
what you would even think more she'd be
terrified she'd be terrified of a horse
oh I gotta get you to see a horse oh my
god back in the saddle again what no you
don't you don't know what to do are you
talking over there whoa jeez these guys
mean business good God okay why are
there so many of you oh god I'm dead oh
Jesus
I didn't even stand a chance there I
guess maybe I shouldn't stop I guess
that's my biggest problem I thought I
was gonna go into cinematic mode and
just keep going but I guess I shouldn't
stop when I do that and I should just
kind of run and go that's pretty cool
hey that's pretty sweet I wish I could
have seen this guy before civilization
took over one of the things that I want
to do and this is completely
counterintuitive to everything that I've
ever said before but it is something
that I want to do I want to take a boat
out into the middle of the ocean yep a
boat that you know won't die on me you
know what I mean just like but a boat
nonetheless like I want to just take a
boat out there
and I want to go out in the middle of
the ocean where there's absolutely
nobody no one for miles international
waters in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean I want to go out there and I just
want to I don't know I just want to be
at sea for like a week I just want to
kind of like get some peace get that
eternal isolation it's like the same
reason like I would love to go up into
space just because like that's something
wonderful ha ha man that's even
something that's crazy to think about I
would love to go to space I would give
up almost anything to go to space and
yet I probably never will have the
chance to in my entire lifetime that is
something fundamentally as a human I may
never experience is so fascinating to me
I wish I wish I wish and I should
probably work towards that goal if I
wanted to that badly in my life but yeah
in the meantime I want to go out into
the middle of the ocean just because I I
want to feel the isolation of it I want
to feel I want to feel the emptiness of
it I want to feel the nothingness that's
out there I want to know I want to know
what it's like oh this is black water oh
[ __ ] I shouldn't be in town maybe dog
dogs fine dogs fight dogs fight dogs
funny dogs funny dogs fine
oh my god I'm sorry look I'm sorry I
didn't mean it guys I didn't mean it oh
god oh god oh god oh god
yeah they'll never know they'll never
know they don't know they don't know and
now we're hiding we're hiding we're
hiding in a bush yeah Bush hiding they
do not know where I am because I'm
hiding in a bush
they'd have no idea I'm like a shadow in
the night there's no way they could know
there's no way that they do know it is
so unbelievably a good spot I don't
think I know any other way to dismount
my horse then flipping head how are you
kidding me what a load of blocka Lee are
you kidding me I will annihilate your
face
where where where how oh come on this is
that's not fair
that's not fair oh that's so not fair oh
god the hell
[Music]
oh god oh god oh huh what the hell that
is [ __ ]
Rockstar your game is broken everybody
who worked on the AI in this game is
dumb and I am NOT a competent oddly
enough I'm not incompetent I am a good
at whatever I'm doing and the
pathfinding walked me right into town
and that was bad and then that dog
walked right in front of my horse I was
not the one that uh ran over that dog
that dog ran into my horse and frankly I
am going to sue for emotional damages
just wanted to let you know why am i on
the other side yeah the only place that
I absolutely could not have gone in the
only city that absolutely was the war
City I could ever go into I go straight
into it no hesitation full riding in you
know like in Hot Fuzz when he just rides
into the shine into town with two
shotguns over his ears yeah that's
pretty good okay hi guys hey how you
doing guys oh you're not here place is
crawling with Pinkertons bounty hunters
pictures of Dutch a lot of money sitting
in that and that's where it's gonna
remain for now I think he's bait wanna
try them publicly
gentlemen sean is being moved up the
upper montana been to a federal prison
damn oh it can't be rescuing people from
some federal prison we rescue him now
got him loose we're not cutting anyone
loose of course not
Pike's geldings boys I'm moving into a
camp nearby before handing him over to
the government so I guess we need to
stop them before they get to camp
Charles why don't you head up on the
north side and then we'll head up on the
other side of the valley and meet you
that way we have them in either
direction of yeah
Josiah come on let's go see you know
better the government or people whom the
government like seem to be very hungry
sure well we'll rescue Sheldon we'll get
ourselves lost good and proper it's a
big country I hope so well I don't know
that's where they say before but now
they got a newfangled technology like
GPS and the ability to track you by
smell they didn't have that before the
1800s no sir no no all right we got to
find this boat we got to find a boat
this all started because of some bad
business with a bow why don't we gotta
go find a boat sure they do
where ah I see I see okay follow me
[Music]
trail act natural the necromancer so you
can go for a while much as I love
dodging the law and sleeping in the Turk
with you derelicts I do have other
business to attend to what happened in
New York you know life is another
straight road anywhere especially with
you nice to know I missed though have
you run out of people to rob Oh we'll
never run out of people to rob but
without me you'll not find the caliber
victim that I find come on let's keep
them in sight
true enough stop talking since we left
you in Valentine so long is right in my
life cute dear boy very cute
and the talking stopped apparently I was
is enthralled in the conversation I
didn't know that was in you've unlocked
skid turns and skid stops whole art one
while X to perform these moves oh that
sounds cool
wait I'm gonna perform a move now oh oh
I unlocked horse drifting watch this
moves sick [ __ ] here comes a [ __ ] pick
up speed I just wanna get some speed god
oh god they won't let me pick up any
speed the people in the Botero
what is that horse rider doing is he
drifting you talking about my by Knox
you're talking by Knox oh I I talk by
Knox with you if you turn in the last
year - yeah ok looks Irish alright give
them a decent kicking well you can only
imagine the [ __ ] he's been giving them
oh yes they're taking him up the canyon
this is our chance come on boys
to victory oh I've got an idea
follow me follow me only if I can do a
horse skid I'm gonna do okay what are we
doing what are we doing okay we're not
doing anything okay I'm done no more
skidding for me fine sure let me get my
bow I haven't had time to use this
shotgun but oh I'm gonna do my dirty all
over them oh you can count on me for
some dirty whoa some dirty doing all
right come on okay don't cross
you took a lot longer than I did thank
you for your help
question mark you can you Don and loot
you don't want none of this
you know alright fine more for me than I
guess dooblidoo alright okay
so what if I
[Music]
run the arm around the neck of the
tuchus long shot long shot yeah sure bow
chin your dick in your butthole on pole
shot oh hey buddy do you think you can
contend with the likes of me in the dick
my bows leave little man bleep head shot
Oh arm shot
[Applause]
[Music]
who should
I'm assuming the red X is kill cuz I've
only just learned that now and I'm what
seven and a half hours into this game
yeah something like that holy [ __ ]
can I get my gun out Jesus not that gun
Oh cuz I looted that's right oops if I
put it away I guess I know get to do
nothing doing
okay well I'm on load then you got this
handle buddy you seem to be doing just
fine just collecting my just rewards
here don't mind me hello friend how you
doing cliff swear on the cliff oh [ __ ]
on the cliff and the dick got him sorry
I stole your kill I'm a bastard like
that quick it's like Christmas and all
the presents are covered in blood and
weirdly dirty but it feels just like
Christmas here we go another one over
here
nice hat hey I like the shape of your
hat buddy is trying for these
I like it I like it good hat
good hat everybody don't like this hey
that's pretty fancy but I like this that
better
I'm coming don't wait for me wait for me
there we go ready for are you still
banging okay
hello - dude dude - the blue tea duty
gotta lose did a little ooh dude I need
some coffee hang on I gotta really get a
good old pick me up here where's my
coffee
mmm I'll just see some corn then nope
corn
oh yeah I'm like a mid gunfight corn
break hey one more for good measure we
can go that far sir I had corn in my
mouth I was there she's all right okay
wait oh I'm not Charles
[Music]
Oh save me the old slo-moes you throw
all these arm shots well let's see you
up there
BAM
gotcha
[Music]
we're yeah we're yeah we're yeah we're
yeah we're holy [ __ ]
[Music]
and
where is he I oh there you are
alright hey I got a loot break loot
break well maybe not Lou Frank who got
mad time for loop break
[Music]
well good for them a lot of stuff to do
or these all Pinkertons
what is this somebody else's gang oh
yeah I imagine there's a lot of gangs
around here but I don't know why they
would turn him into another gang whoa
I could gut you like a fish but I guess
I won't embrace her lust brother no
found you know nothing means more to me
than this game the bond we share it's
the most real thing to me I would kill
for doubt happily die for it but in
spite of all that I would have easily
left you here to rot if Charles and
stomach don't believe awarded the young
whippersnapper can really admire right
we should split up however you scored
mr. McGuire back to camp Charles best
you got separately be careful there's
patrols everywhere good I'm bossman
parently I'm gonna see what's worth
taking here I'll meet you back there
soon as I can all right I don't know why
they always leave like eating for me I
mean I'm fine with it but they really
trust me a lot here and they know that
depending on how much I'm actually
taking for myself which is all of it
Beni an updated tomahawk I just get a
tomahawk all right what have we got here
what is this like is this like a mining
thing got a mine over there no it's not
a mine some kind of like converted
logging camp or something like that yeah
well whatever you're gonna pick up all
the loot sure do love slapping dead
bodies barely do get slappy happy do
maybe there's something else here of
value - no no no though hmm it's all
dilapidated this is long abandoned so I
don't know what else would be here
valerian root whatever that is
sure okay we'll increase your dead ixb
all right okay I don't know how that
does that but sure cool I guess wait
Crime Report oh god oh god I gotta get
out of here I gotta get out okay which
way do I gotta go back to get back I
want to go home
I wanna go home on go home
uh I see wait because that's the only
way ten what's this stranger I'm not
worried about the stranger there's got
to be an unlock oh yeah let's go
Hosea next cuz that's the only mission
that's over available next so oops wrong
way wrong way
oh god oh god oh god okay good jump
there
Lupul alright go go go go go go go go go
go go go go is that a fort it's like a
bird down husk it before unknown suspect
they say yeah it sounds about right
yeah they don't know who did it so
they're never gonna it they're never
gonna trace it back to me just a bunch
of dead bottle hang on opportunity marry
you
where are you going where you going
where you going where'd you go where'd
you go I see you
there you go you go I think I hit it but
I just don't know where it went
yeah whatever it's okay I'm going the
wrong way though I need to uh I need to
not fall off the mountain into the river
of death I need to go down and yeah I
should be good to cross here and then
the long road back to civilization
except here I have a huge bounty on my
head
rabbit hell yeah horse horse man horse
back rabbit kills hell yeah you know
that that's how I'd do it
wait I think I see a deer yeppers gotcha
got you got you sorry sorry about this
it's gotta be done gotta be done I mean
it doesn't gotta be done I guess but I
gotta be done I got it I gotta have one
successful one I have not had one
successful hunt this entire time so this
is a point of pride and it's also a
video game so I guess I'm okay
Oh big boy Oh what in the [ __ ] I gotta
have one successful hunt just just just
one just one one successful hunt that's
all I want one hunt I'll pay off my
bounty if I can make some money from the
hunts but you gotta let me hunt so I can
pass the about a let's go come on I
don't know where
we are right now but whatever bastards
those bastards straight-up bastards
bastard covered bastards with bastard
filling okay I've got one skin let's see
how long it lasts I bet I'm gonna have
it for a long time you know it's amazing
about games like this is that if you
were to compare it to any other form of
entertainment that we have currently you
would almost place it up against like a
full not even a full season I'm talking
a full series of a TV show like a game
of Thrones level thing just with the
amount of detail that it has in it it's
not just spanning one season it's
spanning multiple multiple different
adventures hours and hours and hours of
stuff like all taking place all in one
experience that's as immersive as you
want it to be it's not like these can be
made easily this game probably cost I
don't know probably a couple hundred
million dollars just to make just by the
amount of work that goes into it because
Rockstar literally prints money out but
even so like the experience that you get
out of it all the money aside is is
something so fascinating because if you
think about in no other circumstance
would it ever have been made you know
what I mean not to this level not to
this like level of excellence that they
expect out of it not just for the money
that they paid for it but like Red Dead
Redemption one was great in almost every
way it had freedom unlike you've ever
seen before it had like refinement that
he'd never really seen before it had
this sense of adventure that you
couldn't really replicate and like this
one is matching it in every level almost
exceeding it in some of the levels and
it's all because of a standard of
quality that was agreed to be met
no-one's set up a rule it was just a
challenge self-imposed by the people
that made the game excuse me hard did
Dubois like that like the detail though
the animations the environment every
shrub
everything was handcrafted everything in
this game is handcrafted when you think
about that days computers but I mean the
art every texture on every plan drawn
every texture on every character drawn
every model like rigged every model like
3d model like the trees the grass all
also the optimized program behaviors
things like that there's so many layers
to it that creates such a polished
experience it like you know gaming
really does it like it does create this
medium that no other perform ever
entertainment can replicate that's what
makes gaming special yeah it's it's a
form of entertainment that you're
consuming it and like that's that's
great it is or it's great and bad
depending on what you think of
entertainment but at the same time it's
like really nothing else can compare
nothing can compare to living breathing
adventure the distances sometimes I
really do a marvel at how far it's come
from the first time that I was playing
video games on my dad's computer in his
office back when I was like 5 years old
playing Doom and math last year all
these silly dos games coming to this now
you know I never could have imagined it
in any way I don't think anybody could
yeah here we are
being able to savor each blade of grass
and a beautifully rendered scene of a
Western hypothetical world that's good I
think that guy's going to take a piss
the idea that the squirrels running
around you can almost live in place like
this it just makes me wonder where it's
gonna go next
because this is about as faithful of
recreation as you could possibly want
you don't need any deeper than this but
doesn't mean that things won't get
deeper than this because they will I
mean like what is next is it really like
the matrix style like plug into the game
immerse yourself in it completely is it
a West world style like create robots to
enhance the experience of the game and
real-life kind of blur together like is
it this Star Wars hotel that I keep
hearing about the way they're gonna
create tiers of immersive experiences
for everybody that wants to pay more
like where does it end there's also a
danger for it like when you make these
worlds more and more attractive to be
and I found there cam nearby they got
built tied up I'm gonna go take care of
it come on yeah well yeah I'll go why
wouldn't I help bill doesn't go hunting
Bill Williamson fair point fair point
he's a problem we all know
I'm gonna go in with I can't really see
who's who can I get the binoculars here
weirdly enough now picking my head
through a little game of peekaboo here
okay there's one there's two there's
three
is that him yeah that's him okay that's
it he said what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to get there's no point for the
bow like they're gonna know as soon as
it shoots anyway where's my can't hello
hello hello oh the game just break
I can't open my weapon with Hill anymore
what I uh I can't open my weapon wheel I
can't I can't I can't open my weapon
wait I can't I can't weapon I come in
peace
I can't I can't oh there we go there got
it God we're in whirring we're in okay
we're gonna go Dooley's come on Bubba
how do I do the other dually oh god I'm
really tearing him up okay easy-peasy
this game's great stole him every second
[Music]
you got it everybody's so happy that I
could help with this anyway no I don't
want to no don't pick up anyway got that
alright see a Bill Williamson you do
give me your [ __ ] go on it I want it all
I need a better pack that's another
thing I gotta do when I get to the
trappers I gotta I gotta get a better
satchel so I can carry more [ __ ] alright
I'm a horse
toodly-doo - I gotta get back on my
horse is dirty Yeah right okay sure
whatever yeah anyway back to the super
serious conversation I was talking about
before where am I going again no I see
I'm not gonna follow that
anyway what I was saying is yeah it's
it's like where does it kind of go know
what I mean where does it end cuz like
this this leap in technology that I've
seen in my lifetime and I'm 29
so like think about the 20 years that
I've been playing video games seriously
I'm longer than that but 20 years in
another 20 years
like the quantum leap in what's gonna
happen is going to be huge a lot of
people are like no it's gonna slow down
it's like I don't think human progress
slows down like that I don't think it
can I think like we've just constantly
push ourselves harder and harder and
harder it doesn't matter what like
happens because of it it's like it will
push and we push ourselves because
that's just how we are it's how we are
as like a society we just do it it's how
we are as a species we keep pushing
ourselves because we want it we crave it
we crave advancement and like I don't
know what the next 20 years it's scary
when you think about it and maybe it
won't be but I got a good feeling it'll
be terrifying and hopefully I'll be
around for it maybe I won't who knows
who knows anything these days I
certainly do not
anyway I'll let you guys know when we
get there
almost there actually I'll catch it Jen
I want to ride through when I got a
storm on a ride through like an absolute
hurricane of a storm I want to just be
drenched yeah cuz I haven't seen much in
the environmental stuff of this but I
bet it's pretty crazy dry boy it's all
right boy what are you doing it's okay
air boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
yeah okay boy all right I'm here no this
is Seamus he's our new partner i hain't
no such thing
respective new partner if he likes like
can paint the problem trust in is as I
said your voices down I don't want my
boss here and this is a sideline of
course look at us honest as the day is
long
exactly I'll tell you what let us prove
ourselves ourselves to this car would
you talk about
good day Hosea good luck with your
business dealings listen he's rough and
ready and quick with his tongue but I
swear you can trust him and trust me I'm
an old man and not old shames I'm old
enough and you know why ain't dad
you don't trust idiots exactly we're not
idiots let us prove it to you okay I'll
tell you what Clark
Oh Bob Crawford has boys just bought a
beautiful stolen stagecoach from upstate
it's in their barn man you go get that
and then we can work together who's old
Bob Crawford an acquaintance of mine do
you want us to take out your competition
well he's not just an acquaintance but a
cousin by marriage I also want to see if
you boys got what it takes you survive
that where is he he's in a farmhouse
just northwest of here called Carmody
Dell that's just off the train tracks as
you heading up towards Fort Wallace
there's also some money in that house
but that's your business not mine but
don't kill nobody
folks know we ain't intimate no more and
they'll know it was me but you're fine
with us robbing your cousin by marriage
and yes I love it
you heard the man let's go rob his
cousin by marriage by marriage all right
Bob marriage I think we all can
understand what that means by marriage
I've got this elk skin can I sell it do
you wanna buy it really lead the way
he said the place is just
Westy hear me the other one who's been
out gallivanting around here oh I forgot
I can do this watch out my moves are too
quick for you old man
[Music]
if the two of us can't steal the
stagecoach from sheamus's old crooked
cousin by marriage I mean we could
Oh
tapping X in time with your horses
gallop will stop its stamina draining I
didn't know that I didn't know that at
all
why am I only learning that now yeah I
don't know I'd rather go horsey Oh drift
over here three two one oh come on let
me scoot all right whatever
all right what are we dealing with all
right where did you go
Hosea you're not on my map
Hosea Moselle oh yeah yeah where are you
Jose uh I don't know where Hosea ran off
to you house it is it was it
Hosea
oh man you're sneaky
you're real sneaky I like that all right
I'll take this wait until nightfall
sneak in then I'll get the coach you can
try the house what do you think uh I
like night
let's do night little night robbery nice
wait yeah why not
why wouldn't we wait why would you do it
in broad daylight right now they're
definitely not gonna notice us out
smoking on this rock here okay let's go
you got a buddy they're definitely not
sleeping in that house now
all right sneak mood engaged doodlee do
one sneaky is gonna be doodly-doo god
damn this moon is bright you know what
was about as bright as I've ever seen
anything let's see if I can get up to
the second floor hey I could just sneak
in the back door seems like a definite
something I can do
oh never mind that would be a bad idea
there's someone sleeping right there man
that's a dangerous door to sleep at yeah
I'm a peep okay we got
okay there's definitely someone there
and that's fine don't need to worry
about that let me see if I can get up
nope - hi okay so I got to be slightly
expeditious about this now I gotta
imagine that they would have locked
their front door that seems like an
obvious thing if you have to climb up
here and yeah yeah yeah they're not
gonna notice this is there a window back
here that I could climb okay smooth is
butter here we go
oh [ __ ] ah okay so what was the point of
climbing up that I think I don't know
you know what I'm just gonna forget it
I'm gonna go in one of these windows go
in and let's do this how do I get in
maybe I maybe I could have just gone in
the front door maybe maybe that's what
maybe that's what I should have done
from the get-go front door is wide open
I'm dumb pearl necklace okay good thing
to keep right by the front door yeah
it's fine get someone back there I don't
want to go in there Apple Garrett this
food count is loot yeah dude garlic
you sneaky sneaky sneaky
oh the sneakiest ox capias
okay everybody
Oh buddy all right I guess we got to go
back here now
nobody knows nothing for nobody
[Music]
okay one little more thing
okay let's get out of here
like a shadow get on good boy okay all
right mother sad I was gonna I was gonna
go shotgun but okay whatever
come on get on and let's head back what
is your doing are you out of your gourd
can you please stop being like that nice
singing nice
nice easy there we go and like it ain't
worth nothin like it weren't nothing
alright
okay easy enough
well that is all she wrote and horsies
come on horsies follow good horsies good
horsies well alright I don't see how we
couldn't get it in one piece maybe we
can get back on the path what do I need
to get back on the path I know where I'm
going
yeah
hehehe not sure till we can't I suppose
feels like we're starting to get back on
our feet slowly but surely just need to
keep at it
don't chance a new money just stashed in
a safe spot away from camp but it's a
long way from being full
here we are just pull the coaches
okay easy enough Seamus cousins quickly
we didn't really meet him per se I saw
how they snore mostly like I said course
but competent yeah it's me
coarsely confident find any other
coaches it means selling I'll see what I
can offer you for but discrete you know
of course disputes I'm heading back to
campus thank you coming yeah why not why
not why not come back to camp who is
gonna be a quick travel yes thank you
for the quick travel i apprec-- you
apprecia real hard big preesh all around
big papa priests coming at you hot and
heavy i'll thank you big priests big
briefs i'm just gonna sit back here and
nap for a little bit there we go a job
well done ma'am we're almost tapped out
of the missions in the nearby area i
think we are gonna advance the storyline
pretty soon here in a big way now that
we've got our barons i've done pretty
much every tutorial that they could
possibly want from me yeah i think this
might be closing in on this campsite
here maybe not maybe not i mean honestly
i don't know maybe it will maybe you
won't yeah I've got a pelt you guys
gonna are you gonna do anything about
that
hey that's some moolah
and we can sell stolen wagons just in
general I mean that's pretty good I
guess alright well what else we have
here anything going on alright fine then
well like I don't want to want to take
that here cuz it just be donating it to
the pile I guess but I mean that's not
the worst thing in the world but at the
same time I'm like can I get a little
bit of a better situation of going for
it
ish yeah the only place to do a mission
right now is Thomas downs to reclaim a
dead
well I mean it's the only other mission
I have so I might as well go there I'm
gonna hit the store in town uh before
that but I guess I want to go do that do
I mean maybe there's just like a
threshold of like town development that
I'm gonna need before we're actually
able to move on and of course there have
been like the missions that are just
like but Arthur Arthur you gotta help
Billy Bob is in trouble and then they
come up on me like that but I mean I
didn't even know about my ex until
someone in campus is like hey your ex
called so maybe there's gonna be
something incredible happen in the other
way it keeps hitting me over and over
again
just like it's smaller in smaller ways
but god damn it's so pretty it's so
goddamn pretty okay I'm gonna go to the
butcher right here but it's so pretty
I can't tell you how pretty it is it is
just so unbelievably pretty oh the
trapper
wait where's a trapper that's what I
actually need because I think the
trapper is gonna be the one that's
actually gonna give me money for these
pelts is there a trapper here is there
is trapper even a thing stable general
store saloon barber doctor bounty
hunting newspaper gunsmith saloon now I
guess my best bet is probably gonna be
the butcher that's where I sold a few
other parts before
maybe not that much let's see yeah but
this is like cottage it still fits me
like it's so beautiful it's like if you
were going out in nature anyway and you
were like at the Grand Canyon I doubt
you could ever get used to the Grand
Canyon I doubt it
like it's possible maybe but I mean like
good god this guy did even though the
moon is a little like overtly bright
that's like sun level of moon but that's
for ambiance sake it's like Hollywood
level of moonlighting I also gotta like
get into the crafting of this game he's
like I know there's a huge crafting part
of it but I bet I've barely even
scratched the surface of it I don't even
know how to scratch the surface
oh yeah and the stranger in here I
forgot about the stranger in town let me
go see what the stranger wants after I
dump off this elk come on hey come on
okay Wow oh wow whoa whoa whoa I know
what to do in a knife fight how about
you
alright that God drew on me those his I
don't know why he did that but he did
that lady you alright lady that was uh
that happened okay I'm alright whatever
jerk anyway I've got to drop off a Pelt
now good god I doubt that that was
happening back in the day oh Red Tent
what is that all about I don't know what
that is let me see if I can he's [ __ ]
so oh god he's closed
oh he's closed hey guys you mind if I
you mind if I join you here join you
[Music]
hi mister Hey Oh may I sleep here that
you're just gonna walk into the fire cuz
you can't stand a new of face Mario okay
alright
uh don't don't welcome me okay alright
whatever
cool huh I guess I can go sleep in the
sin that in the end you know where
you're supposed to sleep I suppose I'm
probably supposed to hitch my horse but
I'm not gonna do dad
I'm not gonna do dad I want a room one
room please it's me I really don't need
any more trouble I didn't come to making
I was just protecting a lady well it is
perhaps we're trying to say what are you
what are you trying to say what are you
suggesting
Hey
yeah I'll take a bath where do I get a
bath where's your bath is it back here
is this your bath where's the bath hello
bath this is not the bath I will leave
now is their bath desert okay oh yeah ha
ha ha a bubble bath tub accept deluxe
bath why not living a little luxury now
oh thank you please scrub my noggin
pretty please I already do yeah oh thank
you kindly I'll scrub my left arm if you
don't mind well well thank you kindly
with the scrub double love dub dub
hey let's chat oh wow would you mind
scrubbing my right arm it's feeling a
little jealous of my lefty
good good great now about my left leg
little Tootsie on the lefty a little bit
over there I think it's maybe I don't
know poor thing how about rowdy Tootsie
over there to finish off the quad factor
yes I am I am extremely kind everyone
has said that about me in every way well
we are officially out of dialogue for
this endeavor I thank you for your time
oh oh
doctor sweet kiss on the noggin oh just
like Santa Claus oh my goodness you are
so sweet
I feel fresher than a newborn phone here
we go and like a newborn fawn I'm
covered in blood and screaming as loud
as I can he'll cook a hook
I will take me a nap here wait it's day
how long was I - bonk now got an elk
pelt you are you want elk pelt got elk
pelt here hey you know what shut up hey
man would you like a fine fresh elk pelt
I've got I've got it got it
Oh oh um I'm waiting until morning
apparently because apparently it wasn't
morning okay all right I'm just gonna
hold this on my shoulder all day where
is my ELF belt why am i yes I am yes and
why do you have so much blood okay all
right thank you for the unsolicited
advice
I appreciate that let me see what else I
can sell the general store maybe I can
sell the goodies here like where else
would you be able to sell stuff that's
me the guy who'd be back let me just go
ahead and sell up can I sell this [ __ ]
why can't I sell it by damn it god damn
you damn you damn you for making me want
to kill you damn you okay whatever
we gotta you're going cuz I got to see
what the stranger wants over here also
the bank law office gunsmith I could
sell some of the gunsmith hello
wait you're that fell over had to fight
with Tommy outside of Smithfield no I'm
not people are still talking about that
fine all right fair enough
now there's Tommy anyway how can I help
you today
I don't know customized something that
sounds pretty cool cleaning myself I'm
not worried about it all right goodbye
you ain't no help at all I'm gonna go
see what the stranger is all about no
shut up where's this stranger stranger
[Music]
it's not Punk
mr. Calloway sir its history this is Jim
boy Calloway V Jim boy Calloway the
gunslinger fastest left-handed draw that
ever drew breath he once killed 14 men
in a fight at loozy Hollow what are you
waiting for
how do you mean well I reckon right now
kill him yourself I don't want to kill
him I want to deify him he's a god I'm
trying to write his biography how's that
going
I think I prefer the duel either I'd
kill him and be able to be Baltimore's
finest ever gunslinger or he'd kill me
and I could be set free from ever having
to speak you're starting to understand
something very important like that the
jaws of gun-slinging it's win-win treat
him or glory that's brilliant
I'm gonna write that down if I may be my
gasps what's your name I don't have a
name but you are a gunslinger not really
I mean folks who need shooting not try
and shoot in the back all that other
stuff
well buck but you fought duels once upon
a time man and you ain't interested in
Fame I don't think so
strange but you like fortune I need
money sure okay and forgive me mister if
I seem a little desperate I am a little
desperate this book I've got to make a
thing of it and well there's a whole
list of gunfighters legends every last
one Emmet Granger Flacco Hernandez Billy
midnight black Bell never heard of him
maybe you can go and speak to them ask
him about Callaway any of them get up at
he shoot him I can't believe I just said
that but you want me to go and find some
sad deluded fools like him ask if he was
the greatest and then if they get uppity
shoot him does sound a lot worse than it
did in my head how much pain well a lot
half the proceeds of the book if you
help me get it written I'll see what I
can do Oh get photos okay
and there are notes on the back of those
portraits that should lead you to him
I'll see what I can find out I imagine
you'll be stuck here upon your return
here are some other flophouse okay easy
enough
all right okay all right flippity
doo-dah whoo whoo all right married six
times the six gentleman's gamblers
robbers outlaws and he never divorced
dresses in her widow's weeds ah do not
approach too dangerous for mere
biographer okay blue water marsh that's
interesting okay what about uh about the
other ones
don't I have another one Oh gate guess
that's all I need to know about that one
what if I read more I want to read more
come on give me more okay black Bell
Billy midnight hello
these guys are old right now anyway man
who killed rabbit Matthews little known
about midnight Beth killing
to save for regular sightings at roads
train station ask for him there Oh gate
man's fine me no no no not that
I always forget which one's the satchel
I almost forget whose is when Flaco
Hernandez you got it buddy Flaco away
wanted in eight states unlikely
conversation will proceed with cows and
okey-dokey then got that looking
handsome unless not again no I want to
go right last one who do we got Emmet
Granger hey aren't you just a handsome
fella okay a beaver killer Beaverbrook
mascar never mind a rich hog fancy fancy
[ __ ] hogs okay I present keep her fogged
in your Flatiron Lake interview refused
he got a federal bharden though which is
odd all right sure thing well I got all
those locations but still not closer to
what I was actually here to do you my
horse
you're my horse ain't you yeah I'd
recognize you anywhere all right [ __ ]
nice logs I guess thanks for getting in
my way
whatever duck a little back alley here
my sweet horse all right let's go we
gotta go we gotta go we gotta go go go
I think I'm going for that I don't know
probably actually unfortunately I'm all
out of time for this episode here but
don't you worry we will be back underway
with even more Red Dead Redemption very
soon thank you everybody so much for
watching I am picking up some kind of an
accent I don't even know where what from
throughout this entire series but it's
some kind of an accent but thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye